nothing much surprises Imran what rod
anymore the 62 year old Palestinian
spends a lot of time in his garden
trying to enjoy life but politics
constantly intrudes his hometown is once
again in the headlines and Imran can't
make sense of it with all my respect to
a Buddhist and as a son of a Buddhist
it's not qualified to be the capital and
it doesn't even have qualifications to
become a city it needs a lot of things
first of all it's surrounded by the wall
for many directions the possibility to
expand and to become developed is very
difficult this small town is getting a
lot of attention now because of US
president Donald Trump's proposed Middle
East peace plan where it was suggested
as a potential capital of a Palestinian
state on a nearly empty street younger
residents of Abu Dis gathered looking
for something fun to do I asked
nineteen-year-old nad that Hanish what
he thinks about mr. Trump's proposal
it's impossible to have a Buddhist as a
capital because Jerusalem remains the
capital in our hearts all that they said
was ink on paper and it's not useful
it's worthless while a Buddhist is close
to Jerusalem's Old City residents say it
feels further and further away Israel
separation wall blocks most of the view
but from some vantage points you can
still see the al-aqsa mosque compound
the idea of having a Buddhist play a
larger and more significant role in
Palestinian politics is not a new one
this structure behind me was for a time
in the mid 1990s intended to house the
Palestinian Parliament but the building
was never finished many Palestinians
felt completing its construction would
indicate that a Buddhist had in fact
been selected as a future capital of a
Palestinian state something they did not
want to happen and something all the
residents we spoke with still don't want
to see become a reality our capital is
Jerusalem and we don't accept any other
option no matter what they say or what
they do history shows that people's
rights will be returned to them resolve
running deep through a Palestinian town
that's not seeking the spotlight even
though it's been thrust into it Muhammad
Abdullah Al Jazeera would ease in the
occupied West Bank